bilder wie aus dem urlaubs prospekt weil
ich an der türkischen ägäis die einen
finden hier wo unter wohnung andere
finden hier den tod
auch von völlig ausbrechen flüchtlinge
auf in eine vermeintlich bessere zukunft
wir treffen hübschen efron er ist
fotojournalist seit vielen jahren
berichtet er fast nur noch über die
flüchtlingstragödie vor seiner haustür
da drüben ist die griechische insel
lesbos wenn der wind richtig steht dann
schaffen sie es aber wenn der wind aus
der falschen richtung weht ist es
schwierig dort hinten gehen sie mit dem
boot ins wasser aber der wind treibt sie
in unsere richtung und wenn das boot
einmal gekentert ist kann man nichts
rettung sowie vor dreieinhalb jahren
genau hier an diesem strand diese bilder
hatten damals aufgenommen
ein befreundeter polizist hatte ihn
angerufen komm runter zum strand hatte
er gesagt als ich hier ankam waren schon
einige sicherheitsleute von der siedlung
da es hat sich schnell herumgesprochen
und alle sind hergekommen urlauber und
anwohner alle haben geholfen
sie zählen 37 leichen
syrische flüchtlinge viele kinder sind
darunter ich mache diesen job seit fast
50 jahren
ich habe fünf enkelkinder vor allem wenn
ich kinderleichen sehe will ich
eigentlich keine fotos aber ich muss
halt meinen job machen
es war ein schockierendes
einige konnten sich retten schleppen
sich mit letzter kraft durch das
eiskalte wasser ans ufer
es war winter und die anwohner haben die
flüchtlinge die lebend aus dem wasser
gerettet wurden bei sich aufgenommen
sie haben ihnen etwas zu essen gegeben
und etwas zum anziehen
viele würden das heute vielleicht nicht
mehr tun
die stimmung in der bevölkerung hat sich
geändert die mehrheit will keine
weiteren flüchtlinge aufnehmen
die regierung geht jetzt strenger gegen
sie vor auch deshalb wollen viele
flüchtlinge weg aus der türkei steigen
die zahlen wieder gehen sie wieder auf
die boote ich mache viele berichte über
das team danach bekomme ich kommentare
in den sozialen medien viele sagen die
küstenwache soll die flüchtlinge nicht
aufhalten aber das ist doch keine lösung
die regierung muss etwas machen
irgendwas muss endlich passieren
nennt uns zwei drei stellen von denen
die flüchtlinge oft ablegen trotz der
engen kontrollen der küstenwache wir
fahren zu einem dieser orte wo würden
wir uns verstecken welche stelle würden
wir wählen um den augen der küstenwache
zu entgehen
in einer entlegenen bucht entdecken wir
tatsächlich buchen lebensmittel
kleidungsstücke alte motorrad schläuche
wir laufen weiter und plötzlich ein
fabrikneues schlauchboot und drei jungen
männer sie sind überrascht haben angst
sie seien afghanen sagen sie wir dürfen
sie filmen der anführer erklärt sich
bereit fragen zu beantworten will
zunächst nur von hinten gefilmt werden
er spricht perfekt türkisch behauptet er
sei selbst ein flüchtling aus
afghanistan
doch wir sind skeptisch an der
iranischen grenze wurden wir mehrmals
beschossen
ich habe noch einen spritzer abbekommen
hier im rücken wir fliehen vor dem tod
und wissen dass unsere flucht und tod
enden kann wenn die menschen nicht in
not wären dann würden sie dieses risiko
dar
nicht eingehen sie seien 35 flüchtlinge
die anderen hielten sich versteckt sie
hätten den schlepper zusammen 15.000
euro bezahlt für den transport das boot
die ausrüstung die schlepper haben uns
nur das schlauchboot gezeigt das war
auch nicht hier sondern an einem anderen
ort
wir haben gesagt so müsst ihr das
zusammenbauen
die hölzer müsst ihr da hinlegen so
müsst ihr das aufblasen
so gott will fahren wir heute nach
drüber wir fahren auf eigene faust von
denen ist keiner dabei
von hier aus können wir die insel sehen
wir montieren den motor dran und dann
geht's los
ich glaube dass wir anderthalb stunden
brauchen das haben sie uns jedenfalls
gesagt
später lässt er sich auch von vorne
filmen
das hier ist ein boot das die
küstenwache geschnappt hat sagt mohammed
danach schlitzen sie die boote auf damit
man sie nicht mehr benutzen kann
die beiden anderen flicken alte motorrad
schläuche notdürftige rettungsringe für
die tour nach lesbos wir sagen ihnen
dass es für die nacht eine sturmwarnung
gibt die überfahrt sei lebensgefährlich
wir werden es uns überlegen sagt
mohammed und jetzt sollten wir besser
gehen
am nächsten morgen treffen wir hier
wieder und berichten ihm von unserer
begegnung er bestätigt unseren verdacht
dass es keine flüchtlinge waren die wir
getroffen haben
sicherheit waren dass die schlepper die
kommen immer als erstes an den abfahrts
und sie spielen aus ob sich in der nähe
polizei oder die küstenwache befindet
wenn die luft rein ist rufen sie an und
kurz darauf kommen die flüchtlinge nach
die schlepper sind meistens syrer
afghanen gibt es auch aber die sind er
gutmütig die syrischen schlepper dagegen
verstehen keinen spaß
was er da gemacht habt war sehr
gefährlich
ihr hättet sofort abbauen soll mir ist
es drei mal passieren dass sie auf mich
geschossen
einmal hat einer mit seiner waffe auf
mein ohr geschlagen das ist jetzt auch
eine kamera haben sie auch zerstört
glaubt nicht dass sie bei dem starken
wind losgefahren sind in diesem fall
hätten wir schon die todesnachricht
bekommen
die wären alle ertrunken und die hälfte
der leichen hätten sie heute morgen am
strand gefunden
dann bekommt er tatsächlich einen anruf
von der polizei
wir sollen zur sozialstation kommen ein
bus bringt 35 afghanische flüchtlinge
sie seien bei einer patrouille am
vorabend aufgegriffen wurden
außerdem habe man drei schlepper
festgenommen sie hätten ausgesagt uns
getroffen zu haben
die drei bleiben hinter gittern die
flüchtlinge kommen in ein auffanglager
ende eines fluchtversuchs doch sie
werden es wohl sehr bald noch einmal
versuchen